-The president gave a speech
on Saturday
about the government shutdown
and offered an immigration deal
that both Democrats
and hard-line conservatives
have rejected.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
President Trump's speech
on Saturday
was mostly just a collection of
the same debunked talking points
he's been repeating for weeks.
And as usual,
he spent the whole time
sucking in air like
he was running a marathon.
Here are some highlights.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
[ Laughter ]
-Good Lord!
That sounded like
the first 20 minutes
of a movie about Pablo Escobar.
[ Laughter ]
Maybe Trump is laboring
because he knows every time
he gives one of these speeches,
it gets harder and harder
to convince people.
On Saturday, for example,
he floated a new proposal.
In exchange for wall money, he
would offer temporary extensions
for recipients of two programs
that protect immigrants
known as DACA and TPS.
And not only
did Democrats reject it,
but so did
hard-line conservatives.
Right-wing pundit Ann Coulter
tweeted,
"Trump proposes amnesty.
We voted for Trump and got Jeb."
Wow.
She compared him to Jeb Bush,
his nemesis from the primaries.
Trump prides himself
on being a master negotiator.
Here is actual footage
of Jeb Bush's
most successful negotiation.
-Please clap.
[ Laughter ]
-But, of course, the guy's --
The comparison is unfair.
It's ridiculous.
I mean, it's not like Trump
has ever asked a crowd
to give him a standing ovation.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Get up.
-Oh, my God.
It's happening!
He's turning into Jeb.
Soon he's going to start
wearing glasses
and getting trapped
in his own hoodie.
[ Laughter ]
Even Trump's speeches
are low-energy now.
When he runs for re-election
in 2020,
the primary debates are just
going to be a split screen
of him making faces at himself.
-That is our plan.
Border security, DACA, TPS,
and many other things.
-Now, we are living
in a very surreal time
where people like Ann Coulter
have tremendous sway
over the president.
In December, Trump was going to
give up on the wall
until Coulter
called him a gutless
and a vulgar publicity hound.
He then went to try
to win her back.
Trump shut down the government.
And once again,
after Coulter insulted him
and called the deal amnesty,
Trump scrambled to make
her happy by tweeting,
"No, amnesty is not
a part of my offer."
Man, why is he
so subservient to her?
Does she have
a different pee tape?
[ Laughter ]
Here's the thing.
Trump's proposal is not amnesty.
It's not even a reasonable deal.
And there's no reason to believe
he'll follow through on it.
Remember, we've been down
this road many times with him.
And every time,
he's reneged on his promises.
As early as February 2017,
he said he wanted
to protect DREAMers,
the young
undocumented immigrants
brought here as children,
and that he would be open
to a bill
that would give them
permanent legal status.
-On the DACA program for
immigration, what is your plan?
Do you plan to continue
that program or to end it?
-We're going to
show great heart.
DACA is a very, very difficult
subject for me, I will tell you.
To me, it's one of the most
difficult subjects I have,
because you have
these incredible kids.
We are going to deal with DACA
with heart.
The DACA situation
is a very, very --
It's a very difficult thing
for me.
Because, you know,
I love these kids.
I love kids.
I have kids.
-"I have kids!
I've only ever tried
to deport two of them.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, boys.
Back to Transylvania."
[ Laughter ]
That was in February 2017.
In September,
Trump canceled the program.
Then in January,
he told lawmakers
he was open to a compromise.
And then two days after that,
he completely
changed his mind again.
And even Republican senator
Lindsey Graham,
who brokered the compromise
and has become one of Trump's
closest allies in Congress,
was stunned by Trump's
sudden change of heart.
-Tuesday we had a president
that I was proud to golf with,
call my friend,
who understood immigration
had to be bipartisan.
You had to have border security.
It's essential.
You have border security
with the wall,
but he also understood the idea
that we had to do it
with compassion.
Now, I don't know
where that guy went.
I want him back.
-Oh! Why did he suddenly
change his mind out of nowhere?
Because he's President Werewolf!
Except he's a werewolf
29 days a month
and then there's a full moon,
he turns into a human,
and you can talk to him.
And then all you dummies
celebrate
because you think
it's permanent.
Then the full moon goes away,
and he goes back to chasing you
through the woods.
[ Laughter ]
You can't negotiate with someone
who doesn't know anything,
who changes his mind constantly,
and who lives in fear of
Ann Coulter's Twitter account.
There's really only one person
who can end this shutdown
right now,
and that's Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell.
The Senate has already passed a
bill to keep the government open
with no strings attached.
All McConnell has to do
is pass that same bill again
and override
the president's veto,
and the government
would open up immediately,
which is why a group
of freshmen Democrats,
led by Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez,
showed up in his office
last week
demanding to know
what he was doing.
-We have voted repeatedly,
over and over again,
to reopen the government.
We went to his office
in the Capitol.
here in the Russell Building.
We went to the floor.
-To the cloakroom.
-We went to the cloakroom.
He's not in the cloakroom.
He's not in the Capitol.
He's not in
the Russell Building.
He's not in the floor
of the Senate,
and 800,000 people
don't have their paychecks.
So where's Mitch?
-I mean -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Although I will say, if you're
ever wondering where's Mitch,
just go down to the marsh
and check the lily pads.
[ Laughter ]
We've been down this road
with Trump before.
And there's no reason
to trust him
any more than we have
in the past.
The Senate could pass a bill
right now
to reopen the government.
In the meantime, millions of
people are needlessly suffering,
and all the president
has to say to them is...
-[ Breathing heavily ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]